[Musique]
faites gaffe à l'autre la moder des
ciels et bien cuites déjà comme les
négociants face et dans les maisons de
vin ici après une dégustation on leur
faisait toujours déguster l'entrecôte de
bercy ils n'ont continuer tous les
vendredis on a droit à ce régime
menacent toujours poursuivre un peu la
tradition les traditions du vieux paris
risque cependant d'être bien bousculer
et d'ici peu de temps
à quelques mètres de là s'élèvera le
nouveau vélodrome d'hiver un gigantesque
projet qui inquiète déjà bien des
riverains
dix mille personnes en puissance 22
disciplines sportives plus les annexes
les musées des sports et les parkings
bien entendu les associations
s'organisent pour sauver ce véritable
témoignage de la petite histoire
parisienne
un témoignage qu'il ne faudrait pas
cependant conserver en son état actuel
ce serait rétro grade si on voulait le
conserver dans les vagues
mais nous pensons qu'on peut très bien
rénové bercy en lui donnant une vitalité
nouvelle et faire de bercy un village
qui serait unique en france par son
emplacement par son environnement et par
la vie qu'on pourrait timoner cela
implique la conservation des 900 arbres
et de l'activité vinicole la
réhabilitation des meilleures maisons et
pourquoi pas la création d'un musée du
vin ou des métiers d'art mais chacun a
sa petite idée sur la transformation
futur des lieux on a démoli
il ya du veto il ya des herbes folles
qui va remplacer par un centre
d'animation populaire pour la masse
particulièrement vivant accessible à
tous cet inventaire me le dire par là
c'est un massacre
c'est une véritable résurrection une
résurrection sans doute en tout cas pour
ceux qui seront loin de bercy mais on a
tout lieu de craindre que les riverains
proches du vélodrome est à subir de
grosses nuisances telles que la foule le
bruit ou encore les voitures
et puis que réserve la suite du projet
on a toujours évité d'envisager de la
rénovation complète des 40 hectares
alors que nous nous levons donc ses
terres en pétard fasse partie d'un
projet général où on saura exactement ce
que deviennent bercy le maire a créé des
concepts des commissions spéciales dont
consulter le maximum de gens la
commission d'autres cadres du 2è
arrondissement a été consulté à trois
reprises au lieu d'une et on a fait
appel au cours de ces réunions de
commissions d'arrondissement aux
contestataires aux associations du
collectif bercy je suis moi même allé
plusieurs fois devant mairie du iième
pour eux m'expliquer avec eux ces
concertations représentative pour non je
n'en sais rien en tout cas en cette
épique au maximum
principaux concernés les négociants en
vin ce projet ne risque-t-il pas à plus
ou moins long terme de faire disparaître
complètement
les représentants de cette profession il
y à une indemnité de plusieurs millions
versés par la ville parie qu'ils
n'étaient pas tenues pour qu ils pas le
moindre problème d'emploi pour qui pas
le moindre licenciement
et ça c'est très bien placé et faut pas
dire du tout que ce secteur la perte
avec assure vinicole au contraire on va
restructurer toute la partie est du
secteur et on va assurer un avenir des
motifs très bien sûr l'artisanal que sur
le plot vrille et autres industriels
passent tous secteurs de bercy dites moi
monsieur fanton il a quel âge ses gestes
à ce geste vous savez immémoriale depuis
que le vin existent on la déguste et
c'est bien naturel mais ici là environ
120 ans pour vous la proximité du
vélodrome serait une nuisance est
inquiétante
on peut quand même conclure que c'est la
mort d'un des plus beaux espaces de
paris certes radars la ville voulait
dire
d'un espace baril qui était complètement
mort c'est à ce que pelé dit ah vous
trompez de mots jouent pas aidé de
contraire de votre pensée l'espère
[Musique]